you're free Cersei Ilyn Payne the
mountain beric Dondarrion
Sarris of man the red woman
Tom Hanks congratulations on the finale
which Rock called it drove people crazy
yes you must have read that script with
some trepidation I did yeah you must
have been shocked no a lot of people
know they were going home well well when
they read the scripts obviously yes
sometimes if you're lucky I think you
get kind of spoken to you beforehand but
no but um but the latest the last death
was definitely there yeah that was that
was a tough one out of nowhere now one
of the people who sadly didn't make it
was a correlate husband Khal Drogo
there's a whiff of Conan about there you
go well yes there is yes yes and all the
stuff with him seemed quite dark and
brutal yes but but Bernie the walls some
levity involved he wasn't that was he's
a he's a funny man
very funny a little bit of whiskey and
he's very funny oh but it's burning in
the dark with scenes in the darkest
scenes yes so there was there was there
was the the lovely the lovely and rape
scene where I read what could happen
kind of early on in season 1 and he
tried to call it
nervous laughter so yeah obviously
there's nudity and you kind of to try
and like lighten the mood not only was
it a sex scene but it was a kind of
violent sex scene so he decided to for
one of the scenes which was on his back
and my face he decided to not use a
modesty sock but use a beautiful pink
fluffy sock from me looking petrified
and just like did I didn't want it to
happen was just mean we must be aware
that you're in the biggest show in the
world well done you know really no other
place is bigger please don't push the
girls dreams Brad but here's an honor
it's very rare we have a guest who is on
a stamp
[Applause]
seeing this ya have to be dead together
your character killed not yet please let
me let me put on my glasses Oh fantastic
how much does this can't go for 1 pence
you don't know you and your email this
character is the closest to yourself
you've ever played yeah in in that I'm
not really like Khaleesi mother of
dragons
[Laughter]
Game of Thrones yes you do a lot of
horse acting
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm an all right horse or when they
taught me to ride a horse but if we did
have a scene where it was a very very
fatty horse and it wouldn't go whatever
the Technic whatsoever making a horse go
yeah well I wouldn't with a kick it
wouldn't go but anyway but all the way
up well we and I were doing our lines
and it's a scene where we get quite
always a bad scene yeah well yeah yes
yeah yeah yeah and that was one of my
audition scenes which was quite
interesting but no but I thought that
the audition scene was the other way
around
yes it was the other way around so in
the actual scene it was Alfie working
away on me but in the audition working
away something she doesn't ask about it
means you talking about healthy working
at well knew it might be quite strange
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in the original scripts it was my
character it said Yara and my character
is worrying his [ __ ] did you leave the
hub on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
centimorgan three
it's double whammy because people I mean
it's so weird because why would fans
want to know what's going to happen and
yet they have to know yeah and you've
had quite extreme things but really the
Game of Thrones thing yeah that was
really extreme I was having a root canal
sir every time root canal surgery and I
was in the chair at the dentist and
there was a clamp holding my mouth open
had the beard but all the lovely plastic
things around there and I was reclined
back in the chair feeling you know not
it wasn't an ideal situation really and
the dentist left the room and I'm lying
there with the mouth open and the dental
nurse hits me on the thighs says no tell
me what happened dude game of throne
[Music]
what's it like being naked with Jamie
Lannister is it sexy tummy
[Laughter]
Jason below you do speak some Dothraki I
know yes a few things go and then for
the ladies ginger on that the earlier me
and for the gentleman oh yeah
which is everywhere it's like a topper
it's in every country but friends or
friends of you but I believe your
parents Amelia we're bit worried because
you didn't have that much to do in the
first few episodes no no yes yes so
there's this some episodes that maybe
they're like no it was great but you
sort of not really on very much are you
but but then I did encourage them to
watch the last not this last episode
with episode before which in hindsight
might have been not the episode to
choose there was a lot of you in that
happens it was a little bit yes there
was yes that might be the episode to dip
in too much
[Laughter]
oK we've just got a faraway shots but
the camera did go right in there and did
you watch it with your parents do
between now ready no I mean did you
watch it with your parents yes did you
have to leave the room or did you all
just sit there just gotta go okay we're
watching this started talking about
something really important like top gear
mother doesn't watch Game of Thrones
does she no she stopped after season 1
episode I don't know what it was it was
when some guys arm got ripped off his
body
noise over there oh man she said no it's
too much I'm not doing anymore no and
like she decided to pick it up again
later on yeah but chose just the wrong
episode which is when I was having my
love scene and a cave so got a second
call going no darling very good love
scene in a cave
I like that you know you're going around
the world now and you're meeting all
your fans and I guess there's two ways
you you can kind of go oh god this is
awful
or you can find ways to make it fun for
yourself yes and you have found quite a
fun thing to do when simply couples ask
you for photographs explain what you do
well married couple comes up and they
want to take a picture and then jitan
generally it's the woman that wants to
get the hug and then they want me to
push their husband away so I do it but
sometimes it's the man and you know it's
well we've got some examples here you
are he's like jigs acting this this is
just tragic this next one because I feel
like he just got a girlfriend and he's
properly upset another one and whoa look
at that
Oh beautiful check that out and this
last one is is kind of doubly cruel
because obviously she's killed a pet dog
I'm just pushing him away when you sign
the photograph you Brooke you side over
it is
[Applause]
[Music]
you